prémont belge alors je pars à joubert
une interview spéciale pour vous qui
s'appelle l'interview sans intérêt ça
c'est cool en et bouge pas pendant le
génial
vous savez bien ne pas bouger mois on
n'a pas bougé cers espion à une question
chacun de l'interview sans intérêt qui
ne commence avec vous cad est ce que
vous savez coudre intéressant voyez que
les pieds seulement bien olivier vous
préférez la mer ou la montagne difficile
comme question pour le temps de répondre
la montagne la montagne
cad est ce qu'elle nous a rappelé qu'
est-ce que vous aimiez l'école difficile
comme question
la montagne la montagne way est ce que
cannes je vous avais dit balle pour
lequel il n'a pas vraiment fait ce jeu
rien dit j'ai du mal à wes et de vue
sans intérêt pour vider mes poches parce
que sinon vous allez avoir des petites
surprises avant massants g sur moi on
n'est pas chez comédie d'accord j'ai pas
dis balle vous avez pas dit balle pour
lequel vous avez vu les résultats du
référendum c'est incroyable trois là là
c'est l'interview sans intérêts
évidemment désormais voiture je n'ai pas
de voiture
c'est très bonne heureuse ici des trucs
en même temps je teste call vous y
croyez à ce truc vous
sanquer